signori bellissimi sono tornato con il
cappello perché questo video registrato
sempre quando i capelli alla capperi c'è
il suo band che sarebbe il gioco della
friends on
una cosa del genere allora ve lo spiego
meglio tratta di un europa che ho
trovato dove centra l'amore in questo
gioco centrale amore qui facciamo tipo
la de filippi retro pagato 4 euro quindi
vedremo salutato i miei soldi come
sempre quindi tanto c'è un lecca lecca
qua a si posso vedermi il corpo
bellissimo poi abbassa lo sguardo e vedi
come se hai fatto soprattutto quelli
dove si è vestito da cani però andiamo
avanti ragazzi permesso sono fa vj nel
1996 o un anno e mai avrei pensato di
fare lo youth uberti successo o una mano
wow
non avrei mai detto o una mano nove anni
dopo evening 2005 ora solo nel garage di
prima ti sei visto la mano per quale
motivo allora inserisci le batterie
inseriamo le batterie si world plant
quindi riscalda la pianta questa pianta
ha bisogno di acqua e tiene i capelli
scalati che il caffè
cosa vuol dire che c'è bisogno di
batterie cosa devo fare qua adotterò le
batterie in giro per casa simpatica
questo non trova la batteria vabbè dai
andiamo ad inserire le batterie in
questa bellissima pianta che va aprile
la pianta bafile avete paterino messe
world plant ho capito che ha bisogno di
accantonamento l'acqua come non lo so
non l'ho fatta io cioè non mi spieghi
come funziona non lo posso sapere cosa
devo fare qua prendi il baby caffè che
la prima cosa che deve fare un essere
umano nella vita che succede
lui la madonna ho messo le mie beffe e
adesso ha funzionato grandissimo sto
creando un fagiolo gigante della mia
vita questo sempre siderato farlo avete
qualcosa in contrario c'è anche tutto il
rito satanico che il demonio entry in
casa mia
esatto è invece è entrata solo la
franzoni c'è una luce prendo la lampada
perché non vedo un cazzo la lampada
prendi la non vedo niente premi la mamma
è acceso la lavastoviglie che io sto
facendo delle cose strane qua non si
deve accenno non devi accendere niente
che se non salta tutto
ma chiamiamo l'elettricista facciamo ai
ken read the power in kitchen lead to
the kitchen like cannavaro chef henry
set power henry set palette come fred
aiab sean brady pentola a ieva bella
[ __ ] in the garage di anomalo guidare la
scommessa gratuita da my darling where
are you i'm sorry ai boss making
leonardo da vinci il right here you
can't take my part of the experiment di
cose agli wired e violet air no new york
and not to the experiment nuovo orario
going to eye to you have a john lennon
sunglasses charlene giusti smi ha chiuso
posso fare al massimo ramazzotti ti
sposerò parte a aimi rajlich su you wear
them to talk rai med
flir don't drink fai le beffe e non bere
porca vacca verdi oggi abbiamo dovrebbe
my darling dove sarei mai in cucina
se si sta infatti e si è chiuso si è
spenta la luce a pro si è aperta la
porta del bagno my darling
se hai dei consigli mai darli
sono veramente un figo e non aveva mica
capito di essere così my darling
alternato pure ben my darling aiab son
presenti for you why trovato a quanto al
guanto that can you were to watch dei
piatti and the door smash the two mai
not my darling prisa open the door ai
need to go on on this video because we
need a termino sfide umane tyson youtube
o prendi fucking thank you so much my
darling because the bagno fino a una
certa poi basta da hansen end da darling
c'era qualcosa dentro il muro solo io
scemo that he naso chiesto pure io
darling di you put som semi di girasole
around the sofa no because it's a
problem right now when it's called
giardiniere de cristal chiesto tizio
stato solo a me sembra che le prese
della corrente sorridano in questo gioco
da alinghi few on two coltiva marijuana
you need to back yard non inside the
house please
i need to watch the partita television
tanto satana stava entrando dal tappeto
you remember me no onyx ashley may be
made in
lo scoop un aspetto che danno quel
programma che mi piace io e le mie
ossessioni c'è un tizio che fa i
cristalli a casa sua è un'associazione
parlò allora aspetto c'è un mostro nel
mio garage che è chiuso quindi molto
meglio nostro in the garage che new exit
con from my house di cose e che darling
di you put decolla und sedie decolla is
a chip con because it's not superata e
no chiude across the water because the
planet is dying like leonardo di caprio
sei oscar premi e shawn darling ma di
sport eyes
allora 4 for europe this game
il pay for europe and games fucking
broken rites iphone da glik
l'inte erede in upload porta and heifeld
aun in inferno ai tonno ok little
problemi o canali con back my house ho
beccato un glitch cena vi pare proprio
l'unico sono entrato in una porta chiusa
ma come è possibile
darling and if you la senti mi hai
convinto io non so come si veste ex esco
e rientrano mi avrà salvato spero la
partita continua mi ha salvato signori
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
ebbene no ma stanno succedendo cose ero
contento perché è successa questa cosa
va bene i premi sia piaciuto consenso
vive un momento mi piace anche il
requisito descrizione lasciato mi piace
specialmente per my darling che mi ama
tantissimo se non sta questi iscrivetevi
noi ci rivediamo a una prossima caduta
nell'inferno delle porte
che sfiga bagato gioco da ragazzi
[Musica]